Alex when you teach actors what lessons
are you trying to drive home to them
whether creatively personally if I'm
directing a play I'm trying to show the
person that's doing the part the work
that there is a there is a difference
between you know acting something and
being a human being and experiencing
something sharing yourself what I'm
trying to say is if you want to from
what this was for me why I got into it
was the notion that I could honestly
share myself with other people that
human transaction was what it was all
about period end of story
that that's what it was about so when I
direct to play I try to maximize the
human experience of being a person and
what that really feels like what that
really sounds like it's very different
when someone's telling the truth versus
I'm clever and I know how to act
something and that experience when you
have the human experience it transcends
like that's a good actor it transcends
that that became you affected me
personally do you understand what I'm
saying so so that what I would say is
get real with yourself and when you and
tell the truth in your work that's what
I would say
you